i'm emotionally bankrupt i'm morally
bankrupt and this is not how i'd want it
to end
the founder and ceo of charity water
making a difference all over the world a
new york times bestseller he's a
certifiable badass and his name is scott
harrison the lifestyle of a promoter is
one where you get lots of attention the
fun i had for 10 years in nightlife was
a lot of cocaine mdma 40 to 60
cigarettes a day fun i realized what if
i did die
what would i have to show for life so
that started a process
10
of the world is drinking dirty water
and i realized so many of my friends
didn't trust charities where does the
money really go so i had a very simple
idea promised the public that a hundred
percent of anything they would ever give
to charity water would go directly to
help people get clean water you know
nobody thought this business model was a
good idea and i was hitting a point
where i realized maybe they're right we
about to go out and build a hundred
wells and we're about to miss payroll
there's no miracle that can save us
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
dire river ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
scott
four years
old do you still remember
the day your mother collapsed
i don't
you don't i don't
when i read through your story that was
a pretty significant um sort of
catalystic 1980 right new year's day 19
1980
tell me about that day that week
we had just moved into a new house
my dad wanted to get closer to his job
we moved into this house in the dead of
winter and
we all started experiencing some health
symptoms
headaches and
you know fatigue
and you know nobody really knew what was
going on i think my dad you know had a
couple people come and just check to
make sure that the house was fine he
probably checked the radon or
you know maybe asbestos i'm not sure
and then on 19 uh new year's day 1980 my
mom
according to her and my father walked
across the master bedroom and then
collapsed unconscious both of them uh
she did
and so she was the canary in the coal
mine you know that then led to
uh eventually
a discovery of a carbon monoxide gas
leak in the house there was a faulty
heat exchanger that had been leaking
carbon monoxide
she had been 24 7 in the house unpacking
boxes from the move you know putting
pictures up on the wall my dad had been
working i'd been at school
so we were you know we were spending the
evenings in the house but not 24 7.
and
blood tests revealed these massive
amounts of carbon monoxide in her
bloodstream
and that was really the day that
everything changed for for our family
uh mom never recovered from that you
know my dad and i both did but her life
was irreparably damaged from that point
on
her immune system
just kind of fully shut down
in its ability to process any chemicals
so anything that was unnatural
to give you an example
perfume would make her violently ill if
she smelled perfume
soap
would make her sick car fumes like
kryptonite
would make her sick
so over the next you know
period of years we would
come up with hacks for all this stuff
um the hack for her living space
eventually was a bedroom upstairs in the
house sorry it was a bathroom upstairs
in the house near the bed the bedroom
and the bathroom was washed down with a
special soap that didn't smell it was
completely hypoallergenic
the uh door
the wooden door that had a stain on it
was then covered in sheets of aluminum
foil to keep that stain smelling she
would sleep on an army cot that my dad
had found somewhere that was washed in
baking soda more than 10 times
so there'd be no odor
and then my mom wore a mask her whole
life
so
i
you know rarely saw my mother's face
because she was wearing a an n95 or or
similar version
now
i see your face there are some people
that are like i think this one was just
crazy
right i mean there was an element
growing up of
wondering
of some level of doubt
you know
is this real
um
you know the massive amounts of carbon
monoxide were certainly real and
discovered by the doctors in her body
but
where all of these symptoms hypertension
um
headaches you know a lot of the stuff
you couldn't really see there were
things where she would break out in
terrible rashes and that was very real
but i do remember growing up with that
you know that that edge of
a little bit of doubt sometimes come
from that town from others i think i
mean nobody knew how to process someone
who's allergic to the world
and so among the things that made mom
sick also radio waves telephones
and
tv
so as a young teenager you know i'm
thinking mom is just trying to rain on
my parade we can't have a tv
but i just didn't believe that invisible
electromagnetic waves
were gonna make her that sick
so i remember one night when she had you
know gone to bed i snuck up to the
hallway and i took a boom box and i
turned the radio on with the sound all
the way down and i aimed it through the
door
which it did follow on the inside right
and
you know effectively trying an
experiment to say well if she doesn't
know the radio is on
well she's going to be fine
and she woke up the next morning very
sick
really
so i remember as a kid
for me that was
a big defining moment of you know mom's
telling the truth
and
unfortunately radio waves
affect her and give her symptoms
how can you develop a relationship with
your mother when she's trapped in a room
alone behind tinfoil and
wearing gloves how do you have affection
and
yeah well there wasn't a lot of touch
um
because i wasn't you know i wasn't
really allowed to touch her i would
always be
smelling of something from the outside
world it was a weird childhood i was an
only child because family planning
stopped after the accident
and i just remember
a lot of caregiving helping my mom doing
cooking doing cleaning
uh helping my dad out
with her and trying to be a cheerful
companion i would try to cheer her up i
would play piano outside her
you know like play a keyboard outside
her her door
i had a gentleman sit here the other day
that used to coach kobe bryant and he
talked about this concept of having a
dark side
and he his dark side is quite graphic
but he refers to the dark side as a
concept where things that happen in our
early years end up being both
destructive and constructive
so and they when i sit here with people
that are anomalies you tend to find
these stories because so they had some
kind of anomalous upbringing which led
to them being an anomaly in their early
years for better or for worse when you
reflect on your shall i call it dark
side yeah
i think it's anger
and i've been able to make that anger
useful
by you know for the last
what 17 years you know fighting against
people suffering in needless poverty or
you know specifically people without
access to clean water but
that's probably the darkest side that i
have is
you know i can lose my temper
you know i can
i can get angry
quick
i've i've gotten really
good over the years at
trying to harness that in in a really
constructive way
the the you know the angst maybe you
know maybe it's not even as much anger
um as just the the discontent
with
the way things are
and the the willingness to fight to make
them the way they should be
is that it just con content with the
external world and the and your internal
world so like your life and the what the
situation you find the world in i am not
naturally reflective uh it was it was a
really difficult journey for me to go
back into childhood to write the book
and kind of go back into you know some
really dark years
um of of addiction and
and uh you know well just kind of
decadent advice
it wasn't really fun growing up
and
you know i think now i'm a parent of of
two kids and i'm 46 years old and as i
think about
the childhood i want to give my kids i
actually think i'm over compensating for
fun my wife and i were just talking
about this the other day
you know it is all experience you know
it's let's go
do roller coasters 50 times you know
it's let's jump on a plane and you know
go to niagara falls why let's have all
of these experiences because i think i'm
making up for my lost childhood
you know i i want to
i think i i also want to have fun i want
to do the things kind of vicariously
through
my kids
at that age at these young ages that i
never got to do
one of my fears when i come to have kids
is
my dark side will manifest in both ways
it will mean that for example in your
case that because i was deprived of that
childhood i will make sure we did go to
the the theme park all the time but
there's got to be other ways where that
dark side in us dark side is a bit of a
loaded term but that side of us that
formed our greatness or forms our desire
to overcompensate as a parents also has
a adverse impact which might be
overworking or it could be well it could
be too much fun it could be
you know i could wind up with kids who
don't know the value of work
see i learned the value of work growing
up
i was doing yard work i was washing
windows i was cleaning a four bedroom
house i was
you know washing mom's sheets in special
you know baking soda concoctions so one
of the one of the best things i got from
my childhood was
i was needed i was i was performing a
role that was essential to the family
and that's you know that gave me a lot
of confidence
the lifestyle of a promoter which you
went on to become is one where you get
lots of attention from lots of people
you get it from women you also have a
ton of power you also have a ton of
control my brother my oldest brother
actually
his early story sounds has shades
of of the experience you had in terms of
school
and he went on to be a promoter he
actually was a bouncer and a promoter
even though he is maybe this month the
smartest academic person i've ever met
in my life he was a bouncer and a
promoter in a nightclub and works in
nightclubs and i when i fit reflected on
that i think i think much of the reason
is because he was seeking attention and
the way he felt psychologically in those
scenarios was filling some kind of void
he had in his childhood and this is an
assumption i'm making but i i don't know
how far off i am
i mean if you asked me at 19 what i
wanted to do it was open up for you too
i mean our band was gonna be
instantly rich and famous uh and i was
the band's manager and i was booking us
out and so i'm sure if i played that out
it would be look at me
on stage look at this band
a way of feeling validated when did the
band dream
end
very quick very very soon after uh
the
the piece the the connective tissue
there
which eventually led to a ten-year
career in nightclubs in nightlife
was that
when our band would play gigs
it was the promoters that were making
the money
we would bring a lot of people
our
people our friends would pay the cover
to see us
and then the promoter would throw us a
hundred bucks at the end of the night
and say split this five ways right i
wouldn't even pay for gas
let alone a guitar cable you know that
broke or you know an amp that broke
so
i befriended one of the promoters
that had booked the band in the
immediate aftermath of us breaking up
and said take me under your wing and
teach me the ropes
teach me how to be on the other side of
the velvet rope
you know the other side of booking bands
and i jumped into that business at 19
years old now the funny thing is i
wasn't even allowed to be in clubs
and you were by all accounts really
successfully yeah yeah there were there
were probably eight or ten of us that
were at the highest echelon in new york
city what was it about your character
and about you that made you successful
at that
because that is a very specific i was i
was curating fun
i was creating and curating fun my first
experience in new york city was
with with somebody who was courting our
band and he took me to a club called
club usa i had never been inside a
nightclub in my life and here i am with
you know 3 000 people
and this club had a slide and i remember
he took me up to the balcony and
he's like go in the slide
and i remember just you know you go in
this long kind of like tunnel slide and
it dropped you in the dance floor
and i loved it i mean there was just
something so electric something so
illegal
about it coming from my
christian kind of rule-based
worldview and childhood i mean if my
parents had seen me at that club my gosh
it's really interesting through line
between you saying i said why are you
really good at why were you really good
at the nightlife scene and you said
because i'm good at curating fun and
then like five minutes before we were
talking about the fact that you create
fun for your kids are you over indexed
there
you're a superstar and charity water is
you know
we've been called externally i mean it's
a really fun brand
um and you know this is a little bit of
a joke but what are the first three
letters in fundraising
oh yeah okay a lot of charities would
say shame raising oh yeah guilt-raising
let's me make people feel terrible that
they have too much you know let's show
pictures of kids with flies
in africa you know on their face in slow
motion locking sad eyes with the camera
so we we've
very intentionally taken the opposite
view of building the charity water brand
over 15 years and fun is a word in our
culture
do you think fun has such a big
importance for you and your work because
it was something you were deprived of
i think so and i also think now
the kind of fun really matters so the
fun i had for 10 years in nightlife was
a lot of cocaine fun a lot of ecstasy
mdma fun
you know 40 to 60 cigarettes a day fun
uh gambling fun pornography fun strip
club fun
well i'm i'm using fun loosely so it was
a really unhealthy
search
for
fun in those places
which were highly destructive for me
give me the symptoms of highly
destructive
psychologically physically
it all started with smoking
you know it was like the first cigarette
i did everything to such an extreme
like everything kind of with reckless
abandon you know there's really this all
in i mean if i'm not gonna be an
occasional smoker
i'm gonna smoke two to three packs a day
you know i'm not going to be
occasionally sleeping around i'm going
to go and try and sleep with you know
every beautiful girl in new york city so
i was brought up to save myself for
marriage that's like medication isn't it
in a strange way well or playing things
out to their end would be another way
of you know you can't have this thing
okay so i was brought up you can't have
sex
you can't have smoking you can't have
drinking you can't have drugs
i think a part of me really wanted to
make sure that there wasn't happiness at
the end of it
and to really play it through to the end
so
i actually never felt like an addict to
any of these things maybe smoking aside
but i would do cocaine for two or three
years
and then kind of get bored with it and i
would do marijuana like i'm just gonna
smoke and get stoned every single day
and then
no i didn't find what i was looking for
there
okay let me try and gamble let me go to
vegas let me go to atlantic city let me
you know learn craps and blackjack and
poker and
okay i didn't find it there i just got a
lot broker
so i think it was this exploration of
you know i didn't know what i was
looking for
i was trying to fill a hole
and
i needed to make sure that i left no
stone unturned down that path
are there days when you look back and go
that was one of my lowest days then i
know there's probably a sequence of them
i think about my own life there's a
sequence of days i think that was a but
what was the first day where you think
this something's got to change
yeah this is towards the end so maybe
i'm 26 couple years before i got out of
the business and
a typical night would look like a fancy
dinner at 10 o'clock we would then go to
the club that we were promoting at
around 11 45.
we'd stay at the club until three
we'd leave with a group of 20 people
maybe and we'd go to an after hours
and that might last till 11 a.m
after hours is gross
i mean it's only drugs at after hours
and i just remember this one day coming
back from after hours
and i remember looking out the window on
houston street
and people were on their lunch break
you know the people gotten up in the
morning done yoga gone to the gym had a
full like morning at work and now
they're on their lunch breaks and here i
am taking ambien
to come down i remember needing to block
out the light
and taking a comforter that i would duct
tape on the window
so that i could simulate darkness and
then i would sleep till seven o'clock or
eight o'clock and then wake up and do it
all over again
you know it's not like i'm a doctor
who works the er shift right i worked
the night shift i stitched up a bunch of
patients i was really useful
and you know i'm going to bed at noon
because i've i've been a contributing
member to society like i had just gotten
i don't know a thousand people wasted
the night before
and then gotten wasted with my 20
friends
it was a real it was a real darkness in
that
and the thoughts start to creep in right
at some point that i mean the feeling
probably comes first in that case where
you start feeling something
psychologically or emotionally yes
sadness i think it's a sadness i think
it's a an emptiness
and then you mentioned the health
problems so about a year later
half my body goes numb
and i just remember i couldn't feel
my hand i was running it under hot water
and i couldn't feel the hot water
and i'm like kind of tapping it was this
kind of weird paresthesia and numbness
and tingling
so i'm now seeing doctors
and i'm getting mris and ct scans i'm
convinced i have a
fatal disease i have a brain tumor
you know there's just something when you
the loss of feeling was really scary
i'm connected to ekgs none of the tests
reveal anything
and
that was such a that was a really clear
moment for me
where i realized
what if i did die
in the next month
and what if i did have an inoperable
brain tumor
would i be happy
with the life that i lived
hadn't done anything for others hadn't
mentored others hadn't given charitably
um hadn't been a good friend
particularly hadn't been a particularly
good boyfriend
and
i just realized wow uh i've i've really
gotten to the end i'm
emotionally bankrupt i'm spiritually
bankrupt i'm certainly morally bankrupt
and this is not
how i'd want it to end
so that started a process
when you when people face face you know
that feeling in their life and sometimes
it's just it's exactly that it's a
feeling that their job or the path
they're on is not fulfilling them deeply
and they almost arrive at this a
crossroads where they realize they've
got to make a decision they don't know
what's down there but they do know that
if they go down there they're going to
have to shed a lot of things one of them
is their identity one and everything
that comes with their identity did you
feel a fear of having to shed
pretty much everything you'd built for a
decade friends and
all of that i don't know i didn't even
know how to do that i mean at this point
i just know things need to change
i start reading the bible again i start
reading this book that my father had
given me which it's interesting i've
tried to read it you know years since
and i it doesn't hit me the same way
that it did
then
um
the book was about finding god and
living a pure life
and returning to the innocence of a
child
here is
a man's pursuit of
righteousness honor integrity
peacemaking
innocence
uh virtue
and
i am none of these things
in fact
i am leading people to the opposite of
those things
so i think just what was happening here
was these extremes
like worlds were colliding and i
realized
i didn't need a pivot in my life
a small course correction was not going
to be the answer i was somehow going to
have to
find the 180 degree opposite of
everything i said
thought and did and that's what i didn't
know how to do
what was the first step in doing that i
came back and i tried to sleep with my
girlfriend less
uh
smoke less figure out how to you know
forget how to get out of that
relationship because she didn't love me
and i didn't love her
smoke less drink less
and knock it off with the drugs and then
i was miserable with my failure in all
those things i'd quit smoking for a week
and then i was back at it you know i
wouldn't do coke for a couple weeks and
then i was out at the party and like
some celebrity was there and offered it
to me it's like well you know i mean i'm
doing coke with so and so like you know
can't pass up this opportunity so for me
it was a little bit of a process the
process took um about
seven or eight months
from the beginning of the health issues
to eventually
the change
and that the first significant step that
didn't feel like a pivot then was that
when you
applied started applying to humanitarian
causes and charities and organizations
yeah well there was an event at a
nightclub uh where i had fired somebody
you know interestingly i was actually
offered a business interest in a new
restaurant
so there was this kind of path that
might be a little bit of a pivot out of
nightlife into a more reputable
restaurant owner world where we'd be
promoting a restaurant which also had a
little club upstairs but anyway what
happens i'm i'm at a club
that was there was not one that we
worked at but i knew the owner very well
and i was with the new business partner
of the restaurant
and
i actually still remember this this is
so many years ago but i came out of the
bathroom i remember i was high that
night
and
i sit down back in a banquette with him
and he says hey this bouncer just tried
to shake me down
for money he's like you know the owner
here
right you know that's not cool bro you
brought me to this club and this guy's
trying to hustle me for money and like
you know pay pay me to stay in here i'm
gonna throw you out or he didn't i was
in the bathroom so apparently didn't
know he was with me
so i remember you know going outside and
getting in this bouncer's face
and saying like you know you picked on
the wrong guy this is my new partner so
there's like a there's an element of
loyalty and honor you know here for me
and uh i remember stepping on the street
it was on 27th street between 10th and
11th and i called the owner to who
wasn't there that night i left a message
um about what happened
and left the club and then the next
morning she woke up got the message then
she fired this guy the bouncer
the next night i met the club
that i was working at and i remember
leaving about 15 minutes early and then
on my way home i get a text from our
doorman saying hey bro there's like a
bouncer that just turned up
and he said you know you cost him his
job and he says he's going to kill you
now you have to understand in nightlife
like we get threatened all the time
and this would be like death threat
number 17.
you don't let people in your party
they're embarrassed you know they're
there's a there's a lot of animosity
towards people working at the high end
of nightlife
um but this felt
not trivial
you know to be quite honest and
i remember just saying well um
i'm just gonna i remember going to my
girlfriend's house that night not going
home and
woke up the next day and said i'm just
gonna get out of town for a couple weeks
and called my partner and said i need a
break anyway you know you handled the
clubs for a couple weeks i'm gonna i'm
just gonna get out of town for a little
bit
i wound up renting a cobalt blue ford
mustang
and i think i did a month-long rental
because it felt cheap and
wound up just
driving north you know i was also like
kind of just excited to get out of the
city and the idea of being alone
away from this relationship that wasn't
really healthy as well and i wound up
calling this guy on the phone the next
day and saying hey man i'm really sorry
like you know i was a little out of it
what you did wasn't cool
but i'll try and get you another job you
know here's a couple places that are
hiring and feel free to use me as a
reference
and
you know he seemed like he accepted the
apology on the phone so maybe that maybe
there was never any danger you know um
i'm not sure
but i was heading north and i was gonna
you know get out of town for a while and
i remember bringing a bible and a bottle
of doers and a carton of marble reds
so i start like reading the bible while
i'm drinking and smoking
and i i wind up going through
connecticut and through vermont
and i wind up in maine
and
you know an inner transformation is
really happening the farther i get away
from new york city
like the farther north i go the farther
into kind of you know deserted beauty
the less i wanted to go back
to new york
and
it just kind of hits me
i don't ever need to go back
what if i never went back what would i
do
and
you know
call this a god-given idea or or
whatever i got this idea to
that i said when i when i grew up in the
church this there was this idea of a
biblical tithe where like 10 of your
money goes to the church or to the poor
and then you get to keep 90
well i got this idea to tithe my time
what if i gave one year of the 10 years
that i've selfishly wasted
back in service to god and and
the poor uh or people who who needed
help
could i be useful that was really the
question
and
putting action to that i remember being
in a dial-up internet cafe with a bunch
of old dell computers in greenville
maine on moosehead lake i'm staying in a
little
motel
and i started to fill out the
applications
for the famous humanitarian aid
organizations i'd heard of
save the children
doctors without borders red cross
world vision
and i commit in my mind that i'm not
going to go back to new york
and i'm going to actually change my life
and i'm going to give a year back
i don't go back to new york
while i'm wait go ahead i was going to
say it's just so i find it really
interesting that the further away you
got from new york the more
because people can relate to that in
their lives in so many ways if you've
ever taken a month off from a job yes
and you can finally feel it once you've
stepped away from the thing and said
another way the further i got away from
this destructive environment
for me
you know the
the more clarity i think i got
um so i wound up going
bypassing new york i went to the south
of france a buddy had a house in the
mountains in the remote
pyrenees mountains
and i go there there was no internet so
i had to come down there was no phone
and no internet so i had to come down
into the town on a bike
just to you know check messages
but i go there and it's it's time alone
it's solace it's time for prayer it's
time for reading
you know it's this kind of this
cleansing reset you know there's no
drugs
um i was probably smoking a little bit
but
you know
no no gambling no point like just it's
kind of a reset moment
and
what happens is one by one the denials
from all these organizations come in so
ten organizations reject
my volunteer application
which makes sense because they're not
looking for nightclub promoters
in the same way that uh you know maybe
uh
this is not uh hey we're you know
doctors without borders looking for a
reformed
high-end nightclub promoter to go to
sudan maybe they should have been
in hindsight well so one day i remember
i'm driving my bike
it's probably you know five miles you
know down from this house through the
little town
and there's a small patch of cell phone
reception where i would stop and check
messages
and as i'm actually on the bike riding
through this area the phone rings
and it's a group that hadn't rejected me
and they said hey
we're called mercy ships we saw your
application
our ship right now our hospital ship is
in bremerhaven germany
we haven't agreed to accept you but we
will meet you
so can you be in germany and meet us and
i'm like while i'm in france
i'll get right there
and
i got there maybe 18 hours later
and convinced these people these doctors
that i was not going to throw any wild
parties on their hospital ship i was not
going to corrupt any of the young nurses
that i really was
reformed
uh and wanted to change my life and
the the position i had applied for was
photojournalist
on the ship now i hadn't mentioned this
but i'd gone to new york university
part-time when i was working at the
clubs just to get a degree from my dad
right terrible student c-minus
didn't even see the degree for 10 years
they just mailed it directly to him
because he'd saved up for his only child
to go to college and i felt like i owed
that to him but i had gotten a
communications degree there because it
was the easiest thing you know i was a
pretty good writer and i was a hobby
photographer
so i dust off this degree that i've
never used with nightlife and i say i
actually have a comms degree
from a decent university
and i can do this job i also said to
them i have 15 000 people on my club
email list so i have a built-in audience
to be able to share the stories
of the amazing redemptive humanitarian
work i'm sure you're doing
so maybe maybe to set it another way let
me promote something different
let me promote you
and the unbelievable medical work that
you're going to be doing
and i have a bunch of people that i
could already promote to
tell me about the emotional journey you
went on from there so you get on this
ship it goes off to liberia yeah goes to
benin west africa and then liberia well
this happens very quickly so i go back
to france i pack up and three weeks
later i'm on this hospital ship
and the night before i joined the ship
i had this this moment of clear so this
is a 522 foot ocean liner
so a huge cruise liner that had been
gutted and turned into a
state-of-the-art hospital and this
organization for 25 years had sailed up
and down the coast of africa
bringing volunteer doctors surgeons and
nurses on their vacation time
to provide free medical services
so the the ship would pull into a port
and then you know
work there for a year and then sail off
to the next place
so i have this moment of clarity that
i really am going to need to quit all
the vices before i join this group of
christian doctors and humanitarian on a
ship
and there was something you know
symbolic about the gangway
right like i'm gonna walk up the gangway
of this ship
they're gonna lift the gangway
i'm kind of trapped on it with 350 other
volunteers and then i'm gonna sail away
to a new continent and a new life
i better not bring any of that stuff
with me
so very intentionally the night before i
got on the ship i remember smoking 60
cigarettes smoke three packs my last
three packs of cigarettes
i remember getting hammered
drinking eight or nine beers
and
just
knowing that i would have to go you know
cold turkey or all in
to allow this new life
to
develop
and
you know that was a clarifying moment i
i drink a little bit now years later but
i've never had another cigarette i've
never had a drag or you know 17 years
now um
never touch coke or any of those things
haven't looked at a pornographic image
in 17 years
never gambled again
and actually
didn't sleep with anyone for the next
five years until
uh my wedding night with my wife
so i really went like full circle you
know back home
in the most extreme way
to allow this new
life to unfold
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
i was reading through the book about
what you saw when you arrived yeah oh my
gosh the horrific things there's
actually a photo in here i believe
so let me set the scene so
the ship is pulling into the port
a small advanced team
for the previous three months had posted
flyers
throughout the country advertising the
coming of the hospital ship and we have
1500
available surgery slots to hand out so
we're gonna make 1500 sick people
healthy
those are the surgery slots we have so
i'm so excited right this is like my new
life i've got two nikon d1x cameras
uh and
i learned that
the name for what the first event is
the patient screening it's the big
triage moment
and
the veterans on the ship called it the
screaming oh we're headed to the patient
screaming you know which should have
sounded ominous
so i remember thinking you know looking
at these flyers which are advertising
facial tumors
cleft lips cleft palates cleft faces
flesh eating disease like people with
parts of their face completely missing
with holes that you can look through to
the back of their throats
burns
many people had been burned during the
war by rebel soldiers who would pour oil
on their bodies
to disfigure them
i remember thinking like are there 1500
people that are going to turn up with
these conditions like
really
so get in a land rover a convoy of land
rovers at 5 30 in the morning this is my
third day in africa so like the ship
comes in everybody gets ready let's go
i learned the government has given us
the football stadium in the center of
the city to
do the the screening inside the football
arena put on my hospital scrubs jump in
a convoy of land rovers we snake through
the city we get to the stadium
and there's more than 5 000 sick people
standing in the parking lot
waiting for us to open the doors
i'll never forget that moment
uh realizing
wow
we're going to send 3 000 sick people
home
with no
help
with no hope
and i later learned many of those people
had walked for more than a month from
neighboring countries
the word had spread to sierra leone to
guinea to cote d'ivoire many of them had
brought their children
on a month-long journey
just in the hopes of their child seeing
a doctor
but we didn't have enough doctors
we didn't have enough available slots
so then the door is open
and you know everybody tries to
there's a whole crew that's trying to
put everybody into this line that just
kind of snakes back and forth and back
and forth
and the first child that
so my job is going to be to photograph
all 1500
people
up close for the medical library
and the first child i see is this 14
year old boy
and he's suffocating to death with a
volleyball sized tumor
this pink red tumor
that is occupying his entire mouth and
he's having a hard time breathing
he's terrified
you know i just remember the fear in his
eyes
i'm terrified
you know i remember just weeping i'd
never seen
suffering like this before
and
i remember kind of just shutting down
and going in the corner of the stadium
and one of the doctors came over and
said you know hey you're the
photojournalist guy right like
he said
you gotta get back in there like
basically do your job
you're gonna see way worse than this
so
kind of toughen up kid
and then he said focus on the hope
you know focus on the 1500 people like
this child that we're gonna be able to
help
and that
was two days of really grueling
every single person you see is sick
leprosy clap you know some of the
conditions that i that i mentioned sick
and scared
and couple days later i got to scrub up
again and
document this eight and a half hour
surgery when alfred
the first child that i'd met had his
tumor removed by this remarkable man
named dr gary parker
and a couple weeks later i got to see
alfred
go back to his village i asked whether i
could drive him home in my mind i knew
there was going to be a party
i knew that when the village had
sent this
they'd written this boy off they had
sent him to the witch doctor who
you know
cast spells and spread chicken blood on
his tumor i mean none of this worked so
he had literally been written off for
dead
and i wanted to see what it was like
like when
he came back to the village without his
tumor healthy
so i remember driving him uh
it was a few hours and just the whole
community kind of coming out
and looking at him and touching his face
and
and seeing you know celebrating you know
a child that they thought was lost who
who was found who was healed
and then over the next
year i was able to witness 1500 of those
transformations wow
now i'm blasting my club list
all right the whole time
so that was fun because
in a very short turn
people were getting emails from me
inviting them to the opening of the
prada mega store
or cosmopolitan
you know fashion week party
and now they're getting pictures of 14
year olds with facial tumors
and pictures of
the operating
procedure and then pictures of of
post-op and what are you asking them for
i'm just sharing my experience oh really
okay and i'm promoting the work of the
doctors like guys this is amazing these
doctors are here we're changing people's
lives
so when you drive that kid home and you
see the reaction or even when you see
the before and after how did that can
feel in comparison to the best club
night you ever threw
so much better
so much better
and and and healthy and redemptive and
positive and life-giving
uh it was
joy
what i didn't realize until later was my
invite for me to kind of step into this
new life or into this new calling or to
find the 180
my environment also needed to
drastically change i was never going to
be able
to change my life working at the clubs
four nights a week
surrounded by
sex and drugs and alcohol
but my environment changed and here i am
with a bunch of like you know christian
humanitarian doctors
who are the most sacrificial people that
i've ever met in my lives you know
smoking is not cool on a hospital ship
right
drinking is not cool there's no casino
nobody's playing you know blackjack i
mean this is this is so missional and so
purposeful
and i
i loved the new environment
i couldn't get enough of it i never
wanted to leave
it was home it felt like coming back
home
this leads you ultimately to discovering
that there's a real issue out in africa
with water yeah
and i but that quote
you've got to be kidding me they drink
this feels like quite um a powerful
quote in hindsight when i look at the
work you've done from then on
tell me about that moment where you said
those words
maybe first just the doctor through line
um when i was a kid
i wanted to be a doctor
right to cure mom and sick people like
hers i didn't do anything doctor-like
for
10 years in clubs
doctors don't come to nightclubs and buy
bottles of crystal so i didn't know many
doctors
but now i'm with a bunch of doctors and
there was one doctor this guy dr gary
parker who had been there 21 years and i
made him a mentor
i wanted to spend as much time as
possible
he was one of the reasons why i went
back for the second year
because he had dedicated 21 years of his
life to this work and i'm like well i
have at least another year right let me
let me just not end with this year-long
tithe when the year was finished let me
go back for a second tour
in the second tour
i felt like i really understood the
medical world and i still had to take
all the pictures of the surgeries and
the before and afters but i wanted to
get off of the ship
and understand more of the context of
how people were living in liberia this
was a post-war country
14 years of brutal civil war led by
charles taylor had torn torn apart the
country
there was no electricity no running
water
no sewage system and no mail system so
just imagine like
shambles
like everything broke down in a decade
and a half of war
i mean look how much destruction is
happening just in a short time you know
the what we're seeing now in
um in the ukraine
15 years of war tour the partner so that
was the backdrop of which our doctors
came in
at the time there was one physician
for every 50 000 liberians
okay our ratio here in america is one
for 300.
so every 300 americans is a doctor
one for 50 000.
there were two surgeons apparently in
the country but nowhere for them to
operate
no hospitals they were working
as i got into the rural areas
i saw the water that people were
drinking and
there were swamps
or ponds
you know or sometimes like a muddy river
you know running near these villages or
in the center of these villages
and
i remember seeing kids come
and filling up their buckets and
drinking
unthinkable water
and i was like wait
people drink this
to contrast that
and i think why this resonated so deeply
i used to sell voss water
for ten dollars a bottle in the clubs to
people who would just order a hundred
dollars of water to let it sit there
just in case anybody needed to hydrate
but really they were drinking champagne
or vodka instead
you know as i started to explore this
the water
issue in the country i learned two
things half the country
was drinking dirty contaminated water
every day
and half the disease in the country
was because people were drinking dirty
contaminated water and didn't have
access to sanitation or hygiene so i go
back to dr gary and i'm showing him my
photos like on the back of my camera
like you should see what people are
drinking
and he says i know
and
you know i make this quick link i'm like
well i wonder how many of the 5 000
people
needed to stand in the parking lot of a
stadium to see doctors
if they just had the most basic health
need
you know learned there were 28 different
diseases you could directly
track back to dirty water
so it was really dr gary who took that
information you know he sees this young
kid like
on fire with this aha eureka realization
and he says why don't you go do that
why don't you go make sure everybody in
the world has clean water before you die
and he gave me the challenge
and i remember you know he said
something to the effect of you'd be the
greatest doctor the world had ever seen
if you just gave people the most basic
need for health
if you gave them clean water
you would touch more people than i have
ever operated on by an order of
magnitude
and there was something so simple about
that i'm like well okay my second year
ended i was 30 years old i went back to
new york city and i tried to put action
to that very simple you know commission
very simple commission well it was
simple i mean i mean simple missions
bring clean water to everybody on the
planet it's a few words but it's a big i
mean it's an impossible challenge right
it's a tremendous tremendous challenge
and
you know you said it simple but
i'm sure there's lots of people who have
been given similar kind of flippant
mandates from people in their lives go
and fix that why don't you go and fix
that and 99.9 of them will never attempt
to to fix that which makes me answer ask
the question why did you believe that
you could do that
so i saw the small impact that i had
made promoting the work of mercy ships
in between the two missions there was a
little gap in between year one and year
two and i came back to new york city
with my photos i got a gallery donated
in chelsea i printed 108 of my photos
and i invited all my nightclub friends
to come in
and see
the work that these doctors were doing
and i raised about a hundred thousand
dollars for their work through that show
i remember people callous people
that you know would come to the
nightclub you know who were just kind of
it didn't seem like they would care
about anything standing in front of some
of my images weeping
as they read the caption as they learned
you know hey this is someone just my age
born in a different environment
you know with with a terrible affliction
with no doctor to go to
so i had a little bit of like wow that
you know success and and you know while
my email list shrunk a little bit with
some unsubscribes
at the beginning it actually began to
grow as people would forward it to their
friends and like oh my gosh there's like
this guy that he's like i used to do
coke with this guy and he's like on this
hospital ship in liberia i've never even
heard of liberia and like look at these
photos i mean look at these doctors like
blind people are are seeing and
you know
faces are being fixed and yeah we would
find a 65 year old woman in a village
with a cleft lip food and water had
spilled out of her
mouth her entire life
and we provided a 280 surgery
and she could speak
and she could eat
and had her dignity in her life back so
you know this stuff was like
it was it was um
it was inspiring people the work of the
doctors and i was the promoter so
instead of promoting the dj and the
thousand dollar bottles of cristal and
the you know celebrities that were going
to be in the club that night the special
guests i was promoting something very
different and i saw that that was
working and that that skill
that i had you know potentially learned
over 10 years or misused for 10 years
promoting something
you know certainly
less redemptive yeah or purposeful could
actually be translated and used
to promote
the work of mercy ships the next step
was
i thought it'd be possible to promote
clean water for humans
so and and in effect in an even more
simple way i mean it's it's
what do you do
we bring clean water to people around
the world everybody should have clean
water to drink i thought it was a really
promotable cause and what is what was
your business model though in terms of
the model so how are you gonna bring
water to all of these people well at
this moment i'm broke uh i
am back from africa i have no savings
i've given everything that i had to
mercy ships and the people i'd met
so i crashed with my old club partner
who lets me sleep on his closet floor
for free rent
and i had the idea bring clean water to
everybody on the planet and i had the
benefit of not having any institutional
charitable knowledge outside of my
experience with mercy ships
and i just was talking to people that
worked at mtv or at fashion magazines or
at sephora
and or or the local bank
and i realized so many of my friends
didn't trust charities they did not
trust the system
almost all of their problems had to do
with money
where does the money really go
how much of the money actually gets to
the people who need it you know how much
of the money actually goes to the cause
and
you know the term social entrepreneur
wasn't even around back then but
you know i just took a very
entrepreneurial approach to this and
said well i wonder if through a new
business model
i could
speak
to those objections i could reach out to
these cynical skeptical disenchanted
people
and get them excited about giving
in a new way so i had a very simple idea
separate the overhead
from the money that people would give to
the organization so open up two bank
accounts
promise the public that a hundred
percent of anything they would ever give
to charity water
would go directly to help people get
clean water
and then in the other bank account
go and find a small group of business
leaders and entrepreneurs
to pay for those unsexy overhead costs
the staff salaries the office rent the
flights the insurance the you know epson
toner for the copy machine
so church and state two differently
audited bank accounts
and i wasn't sure how i would fund the
overhead but boy was it clean and i
thought it was a really compelling story
that
beyond just promoting clean water an
inarguable common good for the world
that i thought everybody could get
behind we would now have this hyper
transparent business model that would
speak to the most common objection
people have
to giving to charity which is where does
the money go
so i tried this out my only idea on day
one was to get a club donated
it was september 7th it was my birthday
i was turning 31 and i got a club in the
meatpacking district donated during
fashion week i got open bar donated for
an hour and then i invited everybody to
come
to celebrate my 31st birthday but to get
inside the club
they had to put 20 in this big plexi box
and we were going to take 100 of
whatever was in that box at the end of
the night
and we're going to go
help our first person get access to
clean water and i printed up my photos
so in the club you know it's kind of
juxtaposed with people drinking dirty
water and and wells being drilled and
people drinking clean water i'd also
seen that when i was in africa i'd seen
the solution to the problem of wells
being drilled and communities going from
dirty to clean
so i put those photos up and 700 people
came that night and i'll never forget a
drug dealer came that night he was a
pretty high-end weed dealer
and he put 500 in the box
and he looked at me and he said this is
the first charitable gift i've ever made
in my life really wow but i know where
this money is going and i trust you
we raised fifteen thousand dollars i
remember we counted it and double
counted and like we're taking pictures
of the money and the stacks like you
know because this is your first this is
day one of the organization
and we took that money immediately to a
refugee camp in northern uganda we built
our first water well and then we fixed a
couple other broken wells
and then the most important thing was we
sent the photo proof
video of clean water flowing and then
the satellite images
of where every single water project was
and i emailed the 700 people that came
and said you did this here's where 100
of your 20 went and because you came and
gave
people are drinking clean water and
here's the proof
thank you for vodafone for sponsoring
this podcast one of the greatest tips i
can give any small business owner
listening right now is to take risks in
fact the biggest risk to your business
will be taking two fewer risks
complacency and comfort seeking will
harm your success but taking risks can
be incredibly daunting that's why i've
partnered with vodafone business and
their vhub which offers free one-to-one
sessions with vhub digital advisors and
you can call up and speak to one
completely free of charge sharing your
ideas and getting input from someone
who's knowledgeable on the topic and
able to help you towards your next
business step to find out more search
v-hub by vodafone as you might know my
energy are a sponsor of this podcast and
they offer countless ways to make your
life a little bit more sustainable and
make that transition from where you are
now to a sustainable life 10 times
easier their products are all about
energy independence allowing you to
create a greener home through their
cost-effective and super user-friendly
products and one of my favorite products
right now is the zappy it's a smart ev
charger which simply allows you to
charge your electric vehicle from solar
all wind power so if you would like to
find out more about my energy then head
to myenergy.com and if you've tried the
zappy let me know how you got on with it
in the comments section below
was there a time in that early startup
phase where you genuinely considered
that you might fail
every day really absolutely every day
especially with this business model if i
couldn't raise the overhead
it didn't matter how successful we were
with the the public funding
so every day
and in terms of difficulties with
business with people with you know
everything else what was what was the
most painful
time of that early years the most
painful day
event that you went through
yeah
well the charity started off very
quickly and people loved the 100 model
um it just began to build a lot of
momentum we raised two million dollars
in the first year
through a flurry of activities gallery
shows and events and people doing
concerts for us and people giving online
and we were selling a 20 bottle of water
you know just as a symbolic gesture
where all 20 would go and people would
buy cases of the water so it was just it
was a year of a lot of success and then
in the second year
we were on track to raise six million
dollars
but always a struggle for the overhead
always a struggle to you know find a
donor to pay for employee number two or
to pay for next month's office rent i
mean we were in a really crappy office
like covered in grease floors it was an
old printing press
so i was doing all that work trying to
convince people to help me
build the actual organization because
the 100 model was so resonant
we got to a point uh about a year and a
half in where we had almost a million
dollars
in the
water bank account about to go out and
build a hundred wells
and we were about to miss payroll
and we had nine people at the time
and i remember just thinking and and by
the way people had been warning me that
this model would fail
you know nobody thought this business
model was a good idea i mean effectively
you can't use any of the money you
raised from the public to actually run
the company to run the organization but
i just had such faith in it
and
i had tapped out all the people that i
knew for the overheads
and i was hitting a point where i
realized maybe they're right
you know maybe this is a really dumb
business model so i start calling
lawyers about shutting down the charity
it's a year and a half in even though
we've raised you know millions of
dollars
i remember praying you know with very
little faith and you know and i didn't
start a religious charity so i was still
kind of animated by my personal faith
and
um
you know a belief in in prayer but i
remember like praying for a miracle but
i'm like
there's no miracle that can save us
at this moment
and
the advice i was getting
was to borrow
from the million dollars in the water
account to make payroll so that was the
kind of conventional wisdom hey write
yourself an iou
you know you're not bankrupt if you have
a million dollars
but for me
if we borrowed one penny
one dollar one pound
from that bank account and we used it
on anything overhead related
our integrity would be forever
compromised
you know in such an extreme way i'm like
there's a crack at the foundation i
would never even want to build on top of
that i'd much rather shut it down and
have my integrity
and at that moment
uh
i'd written a cold email to
a british internet entrepreneur um
actually about something completely
different not even about funding
about uh trying to get exposure on his
social media network
it was called bebo at the time and uh
everyone knows bibo that listens to this
so he writes me back and says man i love
this idea like what a what a cool idea
getting everybody clean water checked
out your website you know really good
design and branding but it's a bad time
for me to help
so i don't think anything of it i was
just happy that you know somebody
responded to a cold email
well around this time of near insolvency
or bankruptcy at least on the overhead
account
um
he writes me he says hey i'm going to be
in town
um i'd love to meet you and learn a
little more about what you're doing
he comes in
i remember i pull out my laptop i take
him through a hundred photos and my
whole story he's working in this we're
in this crappy office there's nine other
people there's a couple volunteers
around
and
i remember just thinking boy this is the
worst pitch i've done he is not
into it he's not really laughing at the
jokes he's just
doesn't seem very compelled by this
he leaves
and
you know says well you know give me your
bank account details and you know i'll
see how i can help
and uh
two days later it's around midnight
again i'm i'm
almost at this point just relinquished
the fact that i'm over
i'm gonna shut down the charity maybe
i'll try with a different business model
or maybe i'll just try with the
traditional business model
and i get an email from him and he says
hey it was great meeting you
um i just wired a million dollars into
your overhead account
and we went from bankrupt to 13 months
of funding
he said i believe in your idea you just
need more time
and that was 700 million dollars ago
and this year we'll raise over 130
million dollars
and that entrepreneur was michael birch
that was michael burch he's a mutual
friend of us he was a mutual friend and
and an amazing guy um and really you
know saved the organization
um and i think even more you know
michael and i have been
become really good friends over the
years and
even more than the money
was that somebody believed in me
he believed that i could do it with the
right amount of time we never look back
uh today there are 131 unbelievably
um accomplished entrepreneurs and
business leaders who pay all the
overhead 20 of them in the uk
um
you know it's the founders of
spotify and shopify and wordpress and
linkedin and
you know an
unbelievable group of
of
really a lot of tech entrepreneurs who
love
paying for the software engineers and
the ui ux designers and the actual core
organization of charity water so that
now millions and millions of people
around the world are donating and have
the purest way to give knowing that 100
of the money goes but that was really a
key moment
of
it was almost all over
but
you know if i were to go back and the
money was not going to come in i still
would shut down the charity i wouldn't
have borrowed
really it was that important for you to
is that important to keep good on that
promise
it's funny because that defining promise
is definitely really one of the
fundamental things that has made charity
water so successful in a landscape of
charities where trust as you you
identified very early on is a central
issue with people giving their money
and
hindsight's a wonderful thing but it's
definitely proven you right to hold your
integrity there
yeah
how many people have you now reached i
read it was like 15 million people yeah
we just crossed 15 million people
uh in the last few weeks of the year
in december
in our 15th year so we closed our 15th
year we got to the 15 million
person milestone
um
you know
it's 1 50th of the 771 million people
who need our help
so as we record this
ten percent of the world is drinking
dirty water
it's crazy ten percent of the world
one out of ten people
771 million humans
and we've helped 15 million of them
so we're at the very beginning of this
journey so we're in year 16
and
you know it really to quote my my friend
daniel at spotify who uses this a lot
like it really feels like we are in the
second inning
of impact the second inning of the
movement the second inning of raising
the capital we need to go faster and
accelerate last year we helped two
million people get water so it's over
5000 people every day
so we're at kind of peak velocity over
the 15-year journey
and
in a time where i think we can really
exponentially scale
as an entrepreneur
would you describe yourself as obsessed
because you you said earlier but you
have no you
now driven
committed
not obsessed what's your work-life
balance like if that's even a thing you
you sort of espouse you sign up to yeah
yeah i don't love the balance idea i
think there are seasons when there's an
emphasis um the year before cobit i did
90 flights and 100 speeches
um
then i dropped to you know very little
and you know what the zooms with the
rest of the world and i spent an
extraordinarily
more time with my kids
you know during covet so i think there
there are different seasons of life when
something different is required of me to
move the mission forward
i mean in some ways i feel really lucky
to have
put in the hundred hour weeks because
there really were 100 hour weeks at the
beginning and everybody knows that
you are just when you're trying to birth
something
you know whether it's a company or a
non-profit or a you know a for good
company there's an extraordinary amount
of work that is required in those early
days and years
because you really could kind of die at
any moment like you know the thing could
die
um you could go bankrupt like you're
only as good as your last sale or your
last donor you know that believes in you
so i'm lucky that i got
that
really hard work in early and built the
organization to you know now there's
there's 2 000 people around the world
that are working on charity water
projects every day you know there's a
hundred people uh here in the states and
in london
you know who are working on you know the
fundraising and the campaigns and
um and and managing all these these
water projects
so i work
differently but less you know i'm really
present with my kids i take my kids to
school every morning when i'm home and i
pick them up from school
having tasted a lot of ingredients of
life what do you think is the the recipe
for
in your view for yourself because i
guess that's any perspective you can
talk from but for yourself for a
fulfilled life having been in the clubs
and this the planes the private jets and
yep what would you now say is the recipe
for a fulfilled life service
you think that's central to yeah i
fulfilled service um generosity
yeah it's the only game in town i mean
there's so many people that i've seen
you know i've gotten to spend i've been
to 70 countries now i've been to the
continent of africa more than 55 times
i have seen some of the most
marginalized
um
suffering people living in
in in conditions that that are shocking
i've been with moms that have lost seven
kids to diarrhea and water-borne
diseases
um i've i've seen
horrible horrible things around the
world and then i've been with you know
dozens and dozens of billionaires
and i've seen the top echelon of private
planes and 40 cars
and 70 million dollar houses and
i'll tell you that you know the houses
and the cars and the watches and the
planes and the you know the out market
capping you know your competitors
is not where
purpose lies um it's really in service
and
asking how
for me how can i use my time and my
talent and my my resources my money in
the service of others how can i look
around and
see who is needlessly suffering in my
local community in the global community
and how can i contribute to stop that
suffering
and it's kind of a never-ending work
there's no finish line to that there is
no
you know while i'm trying to get to the
unicorn billion dollar evaluation and
then you know
this is a life of service or a life
trained uh or kind of pointed at being
useful
and loving others
doesn't there's no there's no endpoint
there's no finish line there's always
going to be someone who could use your
help and i found
the more you give and let's just say you
know some people don't have money to
give they could have time to give or
they could have mentorship to give the
more you give the more you give it's
like this muscle you know you need to
use it like if you exercise the
generosity muscle instead of saying no
you know to all the incoming requests
the most generous people i know they
love giving to 50 or 60 different causes
a year they're not saying oh i just get
hit up all the time
they love being useful and and
you know it's a it's a privilege for
them to be asked for money for a noble
cause
because they get to contribute
interesting reframing but a very
significant one so i hate the i hate the
word giving back that we use a lot here
in the states and um
you know oh my company gives back right
you hear about these giving back
programs what almost implies that we
have you know pillaged and plundered to
such extent
to throw some scraps to the port yeah
let's throw a few scraps back right so
we feel better about ourselves so i
encourage companies just drop the back
language just giving
let's build a culture of giving in our
families let's build a culture of giving
in our companies
giving not because we've taken giving
because we can give because it's a joy
to give it's a blessing to be able to
give people listening to this now how
can they
if they're driving up and down the
country washing their dishes whatever
how can they
support what is a very very worthy cause
like charity water
we have an amazing community uh of of
people who show up every month giving a
little bit whatever they can for clean
water it's called the spring
uh uk is our big is our second biggest
market to the us but we now have people
in 150 countries we have people in
africa that give a little bit every
single month
for for clean water
costs about 30 pounds or 40 to get one
person clean water
so there's a lot of people that just do
that every month
and they don't get music or
movies or you know hour
next hour shipping from amazon you know
for more stuff but 100 of whatever they
they give every month goes directly to
help people get clean water and we're
really good at proving where that money
goes and sharing stories of of impact
so um people can learn more at
charitywater.org or just thespring.com
and you i guess you're always looking
forward for individuals that are also
willing to do yeah the the well members
of course i mean if there may be some
entrepreneurs who love building you know
businesses or organizations so
those 131 families are the lifeblood
of the organization and we're always
looking to to grow that really
incredible group that then allows
millions of people to give in a in a
transparent and
um
effective way
scott the work you do is i mean i don't
really know the words to describe i
sometimes think of like nice
adjectives and stuff but it's like a
really deeply profoundly inspiring
journey story book cause
um
[Music]
and future that you're creating and it's
really made me question a lot of things
about myself
i'm in that phase of my life now where
i'm also
asking myself serious questions about
that part of me the purposeful service
part of me and so meeting you today
feels like it was meant to be in many
respects reading the book felt like it
was meant to be but
um i'm sure the conversation we'll have
will continue
off to come with me
come with me on a trip
i'd love to we work in 29 countries now
so i'd love to i'd love to i think you
love seeing the work for yourself and
um water is just so basic you know it's
when when you
when you hear
what it means to people
you know in their own words it's you
know we just step back and it's it's
very powerful well if you'll have me i
definitely will yeah i see that's being
a very kind gesture
um to allow me to we do have a closing
tradition on this podcast which is
the last guest writes a question for the
next guest
the question was
when was the last time
you got badly rejected
i won't use the donor's name but
um
it was
it was definitely you know someone who
just kind of pretended to be really
interested and
you know
felt like was really stringing me along
and then just
i don't know inexplicably
never gave never engaged and felt like a
huge waste of time
and you committed a lot of time i just
lit a lot of time and energy and and was
really you know maybe expectancy
and it was just uh it was a big
disappointment
it normally doesn't happen i mean i'm
i'm uh we're really blessed by you know
being surrounded with with an amazing
group of people and an amazing community
um i just had i just had maybe to end on
a more positive note i had a situation
very very accomplished uh on internet
entrepreneur
um
recently and i asked him for
a very very large sum of money
and
we caught up afterwards after he'd had
time to consider with his wife and he
said
why'd you ask for so little
and then he gave four times more
wow
swings him round of vows why did you ask
for so little
so i was like wow my mind like
absolutely expanded and am i asking for
too little am i think 15 years in 700
million dollars raised you know like a
global movement am i thinking too small
there's more
there's more generosity there's more
goodwill out there so i focus on that
not the rejections it's very easy for me
to kind of you know brush that off and
and
and just not carry that around
and find
the
the generosity and really let that fuel
me so that's been fueling me now for
weeks it's like okay
maybe i really need to go for it
scott thank you
just an amazing conversation on one
that's going to stay with me for some
time i can feel that certainly so um and
your book if nobody's i mean there's two
things there was a couple of catalysts
that really brought me to you i said to
you earlier my manager had seen you
speak and insisted that we had this
conversation and i read your book then i
saw that famous video which anyone can
watch which kind of summarizes your
story in about 20 odd minutes which has
done some 25 million views on youtube
that that had me completely
scott thank you thanks for having me
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete the
salted caramel one if you put some ice
cubes in it and you put it in a blender
and you try it is as good as pretty much
any milkshake on the market just mixed
with water it's been a game changer for
me because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you for
making a product that i actually like
[Music]